capela are now post a question in the
film several times you know why me why
was I chosen and it's incredibly obvious
wise voice is amazing he has presence on
stage right and he has heart and you
just kind of instantly fall in love with
him I'm curious what our Nels story and
arnel himself represents to the Filipino
community as they absolutely love him
and what do you think it is that that
just is it a chance of sort of
triumphing over you know impossible odds
I'm going to let Ramona speak because
she's Filipino American let her speak on
the Filipino community but I can tell
you that sort of the whole theme to this
whole journey that we have been honest
filmmakers and and the band has been on
an Darnell's banana is truly one that
you could easily say with the theme of
don't stop believing I mean um you know
I know has been doing it for a very long
time and journey has been around for a
very long time and I was always a big
journey fannin and I always thought they
were big and they were always big and
there was going to be big but when you
you get into any kind of dive into it
you realize that no they're just like
anyone else anyone's life they have ups
and downs and highs and lows and you
know Neil never stopped believing in his
band John Jonathan Kaye never stopped
believing and I know never start stopped
believing and we as filmmakers like
never stopped believing it's like really
a theme and you know we kind of jumped
out there on her own credit cards we
didn't have funding in place and
everything and the first time I saw a
little clip that Ramona put together I
said we have to do this and she's like
well they're on tour right now and I
said right now we were standing in a
starbucks parking lot she said yeah I
said we're missing a story it's
unfolding like we have to go now and
she's like well we don't have money and
I said well we can't let that stop us
don't let that suffice so within a week
of that conversation we were on the road
just like putting stuff on credit cards
and and we just always knew and there
was one moment you know because we were
so small and we didn't
have a lot of money there was only five
of us on a road so there's two camera
operators when sound Ramona myself and
my job is are sort of two to PA and you
know to drive and just dump footage and
just do kind of all the things anything
else that you know needed to be done and
I remember at one point we were probably
like maybe have the six venue and I was
sitting back there and it kind of dawned
on me I said we're like charging up a
storm we're following a rock band we
don't have any money we don't know what
the movie is we don't know anything
we're just out here and I watched like
10 minutes of our now in the dressing
room and he would captivated me I
couldn't take my eyes off of him and
that's when I knew I was like we're
gonna be all right like I knew we're
gonna be all right was this starbucks in
Maryland two of you were talking mm-hmm
Ramona and I've always lived in in
Baltimore and we've known about each
other and we always figured at some
point there'd be a project we can work
together on and then she called me with
this one and like I said I couldn't take
my eyes off him I was like it's got to
happen we got to make this film and we
have to start now so you were in was it
a van following the toilet even yes so
we were in a minivan it was five of us
all our luggage for the summer all our
gear and we would just follow this band
I mean these big you know tour buses
these big semis and just kind of keep up
with them and and how many times a day
did it go through your mind like what am
i doing before you saw that footage of
or now would note it never occurred to
me before like what am i doing cuz you
know you're kind of on adrenaline and
you just be you just like get it done
get it done get it done but that's then
once you're getting it done and you're
doing it then you kind of sit back and
doing what am i doing so that was like
the first time I know the last time I
questioned it
you